This is quite a sad video because Harry Kroto a friend of mine
and Nobel prize winner,
discoverer of [inaudible] the molecule shape,
like a soccer ball died quite recently.
He was also a very keen periodic videos fan,
but his Nobel prize is particularly special to me
because it is the only occasion in my scientific lifetime that
I have really seen the project go right from the beginning to when they got
the Nobel prize.
Harry Kroto was a physical chemist who was really interested in the
molecules who find in outer space.
He was based at the university of Sussex in the South of England,
and he did a sorts of measurements, school microwave spectroscopy,
looking at chains of carbon atoms,
which he thought with the sorts of molecules that could be found in outer space.
And so much of his research was based on trying to synthesize
possible molecules that might also exist in space and
to do this and his key piece of work.
He went to rice university in Houston,
in the United States and worked with a chemist there called Rick Smalley.
And some years before I went to visit Rick's Morley as part of a
big tour around the United States.
So I saw all the operators while it was being built.
This is my notebook from my trip here. It says,
Rick Smalley down here, you can see there is a sketch of the operators.
And the thing that I think is really interesting is that it says they're going
for large clusters,
which they called new surface science.
So this was the aim of the project 1982,
three years before they found [inaudible]
. This operators was designed to shine the laser on the road of a
metal or solid carbon. And the pulse of the laser was so powerful that it produced a plume of vapor. And then down in this part of the operators, you can measure the mass of the molecules that came off.
The key experiment was that they sapped
carbon graphite and lots of fragments came off with different numbers
of carbon atoms,
but one of them C 60 H was much more
abundant than everything else.
Eventually they worked out that it must be a molecule shaped like a
football soccer ball.
[inaudible] he named it Buckminster fuller in after the famous
architect, Buckminster fuller,
who designed what is called the [inaudible] dome,
which is a dome that has part of this structure. You have to understand,
they just saw some mass in the spectrum. They didn't have any chemical.
So there was a huge argument. Were they right? Were they not? Right?
People wrote quite rude papers. One of them had the title,
soccer ball deflated saying they were wrong,
but in the end it turned out they would correct.
And see 60.
The first new form of carbon that had been discovered for 2000
years, turned out to be real.
See 60 itself. The material is a rather boring black color,
but when it's dissolved in solution, for example, in Tollerene,
it has rather a nice per-click red color.
Subsequently people discovered other molecules with slightly different
structures like CS 70, and which has a different color.
So you can see this one is more red and this one is more orange.
Here was a form of carbon that you could get in solution. People thought,
perhaps you could do all sorts of exciting work,
perhaps make transistors, all sorts of things. The whole chemistry was open.
And since then there have been thousands and thousands of papers published. Now,
what I think is the really important thing about Harry is what sort of person he
was. There are lots of famous scientists in the world,
but he was a really passionate scientist and really
keen on communicating science and how exciting science is to
young people.
He had quite a piercing voice and like me,
he tended to wave his hands.
He was enormously enthusiastic when he lectured
whatever he was talking about. Not always very politely.
If he didn't agree with something, he wasn't shy to say it was rubbish.
Last year, 2015,
there was an announcement that the iron of [inaudible] had been
observed in outer space for Harry.
This was the culmination of all his research.
He had been looking for these molecules because he thought they were in outer
space and they had been observed through the absorption of
light because obviously nobody has been with a test tube to
the atmosphere of styles. Harry came to Nottingham quite frequently.
One of his last official visits was to open a
nanotechnology center and to Mark the events,
he gave a lecture here and to Mark the opening,
the plaque was put on the wall of the nano center.
[Inaudible] conveniently.
The manly technology center is just been refurbished and
improved.
So the plaque is temporarily off the wall so we can show it to here.
And you can see it was opened nine year, nearly nine years ago.
And you can see his name.
So Harry Kroto and I'm sure he would like it.
If we bounced the molecule of C6 state of
the flack, Harry was also president of the Royal society of chemistry.
One of the duties of a precedent is to present prizes
and metals, the people who win prizes and metals.
And he was president when I and my industrial
collaborators in the company called Thomas one, one,
the so-called industrial innovation team award down here
in sort of green ink is Harry's signature
as president of the Royal society of chemistry.
And there was a glass Rose bowl that was presented to me and is now at the
company. But as soon as the official photograph had been taken,
Harry, who was quite jealous of my hair,
turn the bowl upside down and placed it on top of my head. Unfortunately,
nobody photographed that,
but we do have a nice picture of him presenting the award.
He was somebody who was not phased by ceremony
and tended to make fun of things like these formal ceremonies,
which is usually a good thing. Unfortunately,
some Nobel prize winners are quite pompous after they've got the
prize because they suddenly think they're enormously great,
which of course they are great,
but the really great Nobel prize winners remain
pretty modest and they use their Nobel prize to
enable them to speak out on important issues. In Harry's case,
he spoke out very strongly about the funding of
science, the funding of fundamental science,
rather than the applied science in a way that his Nobel prize
gave him the power to be listened to scientists are quite often
asked what they might have done if they weren't scientists.
So there's no doubt in Harry's case that he would have been a graphic designer
who was very good at drawing and producing very nice designs.
One of Harry's more mischievous designs was a Bruce Shaw
advertising the chemistry tools at the university of Sussex.
It consisted of a map of the United Kingdom with a Bunsen
burner on each of the cities where there was a chemistry
department, which was okay.
But the thing that was mischievous is that only the Bunsen burner on Brighton
university of Sussex was a light and all the others were switched
off. It's wonderfully fitting that Harry,
the potential graphic designer should have discovered a molecule
C6 day,
which probably has the most beautiful cemetery of any
molecule that's ever been discovered. I suppose,
if you had asked Harry when he was younger to design a really beautiful
molecule, he might have.
Produce this mathematical friends.
Does it have a special name? And the friend said, yes,
it's called the soccer ball.